لا توجد طريقة آمنة سهلة للوصول إلى أقصى
خطوط الجبهة الشرقية في دونباس
لقد قطعت روسيا الطرق السريعة ، لذا يجب على الجنود
المحليين الذين يسلحون بالأسلحة وتسليم المساعدات أن
يسلكوا جميعًا الطرق الخلفية.
تفريغ الفريق وتصل العائلات بسرعة كبيرة
لتحميل ضجيج الحرب
[الموسيقى]
قريبًا وبصوت عالٍ ،
لا أحد يتفاعل مع
ناتاليا وهي تجمع الطعام لزوجها وطفليها
وتقول إنهم لا يستطيعون مغادرة البلدة
لأنهم يخشون فقدان منزلهم
و  حديقة الخضروات التي يعتمدون عليها للبقاء على
قيد الحياة
فقط أحمق ليس خائفًا كما تقول ، لكن
لا يوجد مخرج لا يمكننا مغادرة
مكاننا. وصلت لوبوف مع أطفالها الصغار
، وتقول إنهم بقوا مع
اقتراب الروس لأنها لا
تريد المخاطرة  بعد انفصالها عن
ابنتها الكبرى
التي تعيش في قرية مجاورة
، قالت إنني اتصلت بها بمجرد أن أخبرتني
أنهم لن يغادروا ، ثم فقدنا
الاتصال ، ولا أعرف حتى ما إذا كانت
لوبوف بخير  لتظهر لنا المنزل حيث
تأمل أن يتمكنوا من انتظار الحرب بأمان ،
إنها نزهة إلى الجانب الآخر من المدينة ،
لكننا سرعان ما ندرك أنه لن يكون من الممكن أن يكون
حيهم تحت نيران
المدفعية القادمة من مكان
قريب جدًا لدرجة أنك تسمع صوت المدفعية  قطعة
النار
تنهي رحلة القذيفة قبل
أن تصطدم تسقط القذائف داخل نفس المنطقة الضيقة
مرارًا
وتكرارًا ،
رأينا كل هذا بينما كانت القوات الروسية على مسافة
أبعد قليلاً من الشرق
تدعي
فوزًا مهمًا ،
مع اقتناص فرصة مدينة لوسي.
للذهاب ، نعم
، ساحة المعركة هي فرصة ليست سوى
مسافة قصيرة نسبيًا من هنا ،
ومن المحتمل أن تكون خط المواجهة
قريبًا جدًا ، لكن
الأسلحة الثقيلة لروسيا
تتساقط بالفعل بين منازل هؤلاء الأشخاص
في هذه المدينة
، فليس من الآمن
البقاء قريبًا.
[موسيقى  ]
لكن كل هؤلاء الناس ما زالوا
خائفين مرتبكين على أمل أن يتعدى السبب أن
العنف القادم سوف يمر بهم